ああこんにちははじめ冊をです学校から入ってきました
あのねあのー僕はんっ
うまく説明できないうまく説明できるんだけど学校がある種だかなんか時間グっていう
んちゃんと動画が撮れないんですよ
申し訳ない今日のどうか
的な手抜きでもないなぁちゃんどこー寿司はあるかねシュシュあるんですけどもあって
前
今日はねちゃんとねいう理由がありますあの今日は学校の授業の宿題をやってから授業
に行きました
宿題をやったからねまあ今日はねご勘弁というわけで今日の動画は今までの僕がやって
きたドッキリの総集編でございますそろそろちゃんとで動画の再生リストと場をつくっ
て色々見やすくしたいなと思ってるんですよ
心霊スポットいったで実験系ドッキリ力は館内のとかなんかいろいろジャンルがあるん
ですけどもそういうのちゃんと理由って僕動画なの方
はやばいあと少しはもうすぐで動画1000本すよ現場も道があるとやっぱりこうみ
たい店を探すの難しいと思うんねちょっとですね再生リストとか
塔周辺と館の動画も作っていければなと思っていますという名のサボりですねサボり
じゃないんすよやっぱ宿題をやると時間がないしねもうすぐテストなんで頑張りますよ
と雪で肇社長のドッキリ総集編です
どうぞおっおおっ
+ちゃいますさ
こわー
[音楽]
うわぁ
主婦の
ザー
あっああぁああん
[音楽]
はいこれは cs テレ bing
うん
[音楽]
ポンッ
r 1だっ
あっ
me
ch
押したくさん終えが動いくっお役さあ
らさん忠南募って富戸ケアないコーナーの方へどうぞ
[音楽]
笑ん
teame
ん
はぁ
4日
か月くらい
[音楽]
ネイチャー
can ん
[音楽]
ああああああああ
うっはー
んあった
えっ
re re you doing
tan
はあああああ
ben
[拍手]
me
ん
[音楽]
me
あああああん
[音楽]